helped save the animals today we're
doing a very special livestream to save
your favorite furry friend four best
friends org so please click the link in
the description below to join us for a
day filled with fun games laughs and
wait loose also this charity livestream
will be done a bit differently today
we're selling special edition t-shirts
that will only be available today and
they come with this very special decal
on the sleeve that says markup liars
heroes it is awesome but will only be
available today and for each t-shirt
sold $15 will go to the charity so thank
you guys so much for helping out and as
always I will see you at the charity